à deux jours de noël ces enfants décidé
d'enfiler un bonnet de bain pendant
leurs vacances il participe ce lundi 23
décembre un stage de natation organisé à
la piscine salvador allende les
clayes-sous-bois le but apprendre en
s'amusant sous l'oeil d'un maître nageur
objectif ça va être sécuritaire
principalement et que du coup ça va
aller avec de la technique pour pouvoir
les faire progresser plus facilement et
qui sache voilà à faire un maximum de
distance en tout cas avec un minimum
d'efforts et à peu un peu plus de
technique que ce qu'ils ont au début
le rendez vous est proposé à partir de 5
ans jusqu'à 12 ans pour les enfants de
saint quentin en yvelines où des saisons
environnement tu as des enfants qu'on a
on scolaire par exemple et qui viennent
pour avoir dû plus y en a qui sont même
en club et qui viennent aussi parce que
c'est une activité aussi qui les
occupent et qu'ils aiment ce qu'ils
aiment ça aussi mais c'est aussi tout
simplement des gens autour qui veulent
qu'ils veulent que leurs enfants
progressent au total quatre enfants
participent aujourd'hui à cette séance
qui peut durer de 45 minutes à une heure
sur les dos sur le ventre avec ça va
c'est assez sens avec la frite oui sur
l'afrique ça va le tarif pour la semaine
est compris entre 56 et 60 8 euros pour
quatre séances si vous avez manqué cette
session de noël la structure organisera
un nouveau stage sur des prochaines
vacances